Any deck I find myself playing for a long
enough period of time generally earns itself
its own dedicated video, a deck tech. That
happened 21 months after I built Sharuum Slide,
7 months after I built Glissa Incubators, 4
months after I built my Malcolm Time Sieve deck,
1 month after building my Radha deck, and also 1
month after putting together an updated version
of my Malfegor deck. In part, this is for
entirely ordinary YouTuber reasons—I need
to figure out 2 things per month to talk about,
and a deck I like to play makes for an easy thing
to make one of those 2. However, this is also
because my favorite decks tend to be evocative,
meticulously crafted to scratch a very specific
itch, and for this reason they also often serve
as good lenses through which to analyze a specific
playstyle or a specific motivation when building
a deck. Relevant to this discussion is the fact
that my decks tend to revolve around a specific
vibe I find appealing, whether that be forcing
the table into a cutthroat low-resource game,
unstoppably accumulating resources for myself,
or navigating a strategic minefield to a narrow
control victory. Because my decks feature specific
play patterns I find personally satisfying,
I like to think they can be helpful documents of
how I crafted an enjoyable experience for myself,
and possible inspiration for
how others can do the same.
It’s with all this in the mind that we need to
talk about the elephant in the room: my Liesa
deck. I first built this deck in April 2023, 35
months ago, and it has stayed among my 5-6 core
decks ever since. I’ve even talked about it in
a handful of different videos, because it has
accomplished some interesting things and offered
some intriguing lessons. What it hasn’t done,
though, is ever be quite satisfying enough to
make a whole video about—it’s never scratched
the itch I wanted it to scratch well enough to be
worth talking about. This is kind of funny to me,
because I’ve known precisely what itch I wanted
to scratch basically the whole time—I wanted
to make people think about their life total a
lot. I said so, in a Discord message I sent to
a friend in June of 2023, and I also laid out this
thought process in a video about aggro in October
of that year. An aggressive gameplan can mean the
ability to knock opponents out of the game early,
but even before that happens, the first 20-30
damage dealt to an opponent already influences the
way they play the game. It makes them play more
conservatively, attack less confidently, and get
substantially less comfort with the lifepay tools
that are such a defining feature of commander.
And, relevantly here, a low life total especially
does that if I can keep around a creature that
drains opponents whenever they cast spells. So,
I was already in a great starting position, with
my command zone being a command-tax-dodger who
drains anybody who casts spells. So, how exactly
did I manage to fail at adequately scratching this
itch for multiple years? Well, it’s been a complex
road of confused intentions and muddied goals,
with multiple rounds of heavy reworks, and even
a commander swap followed by a later swap-back
along the way. The place this deck has ended up is
a pretty satisfying one, but there have been more
than enough mistakes and lessons along the way.
Something I should address before going much
further is that this deck has ended up being
a departure from my usual tight budget I keep
myself to when deckbuilding. Whereas this deck
began at the budget of most of my other decks, in
the $50-150 range, recent iterations of this deck
would cost between $300 and $400 to buy new.
A big part of the reason for this is the long
evolution this deck took—it gradually became clear
that extra budget was going to go a long way,
and I had plenty of spare cards lying
around that could be gradually sold off
to help fund upgrades. And, how I went
about that process was using Cardsphere,
the lovely folks at which kindly agreed to
sponsor this video when I asked. Cardsphere
is a peer to peer card trading website where
sellers initiate sales, rather than buyers.
On the buying end this can mean some great deals
on cards if you don’t need them immediately—just
put in how much you’re willing to pay, and after
that a seller willing to sell it to you for that
price can initiate a sale and send it to you. More
importantly, I’ve found the process of selling
cards much easier than other options—rather
than getting 60% of market price on a buylist or
needing to fry my brain keeping up with multiple
auctions on a more general selling platform, I
can just log into Cardsphere, accept any offers I
find high enough on cards I own, spend 15 minutes
throwing a few envelopes in the mail, and then
be done with things. Most of my sales have been
for between 80 and 90% of market price, but I’ve
gotten even more than that in some cases. Follow
my link in the description to get started, and
thanks to Cardsphere for supporting the channel.
Okay, with that endpoint in mind, let’s talk about
some of the pivots this deck took along the way,
and why all but one of them failed at the task of
scratching the itch I was trying to scratch. To
start with, there were some issues in the original
deck, but the basic idea of what I was going for
was a simple one. The phrase “hatebear” typically
refers to a 2 or 3 mana creature with an attached
effect that slows down opponents in some way or
other, typically by imposing a tax, setting a rule
about how the game can be played, or preventing
a specific type of effect. In 60 card formats,
hatebears are a relatively common sight,
particularly in the game’s older formats.
Death and Taxes is a type of legacy deck
specifically built around this sort of creature,
and vintage usually has at least a couple decks
centered around hatebears such as Archon of
Emeria or 2 mana Lavinia. This is because these
creatures have an appealing profile—they keep
your opponent’s plans in check, and their
average size means that they can reliably
whittle down a single 20-health opponent if
you’re able to slow the pace of the game a bit,
which their attached stax effects already do.
Cool! How about in EDH, though? Hatebears are
still useful for their effects, but the attached
2/2 or 3/3 body typically isn’t nearly as helpful.
This is where the command zone comes into play—my
hatebears can whittle down life totals a little
and generally gum up the works of the game, and
then Liesa is my followup that can really start to
cut down life totals in this slowed environment.
This theory largely worked out in reality—I
had a suite of 16 hate bears alongside modest
counts of protection, ramp, draw, and removal,
as well as some extra tools to help Liesa in
cutting down opposing life totals. Still, I
found myself having some issues with that original
deck. In retrospect the biggest one is that it
felt more stax than it did Liesa—my opponents were
being hindered, but more so by an Archon of Emeria
than by their painfully low life total. However,
at the time I was only distantly aware of this,
and more focused on another undeniably-present
problem: the deck didn’t have all that much draw,
which just made it kinda boring to play. My
opponents couldn’t do much, but neither could I.
So, in early 2024, I did a round of tweaks on
the deck to get more value generation in there,
and generally to make it more interesting to play.
And I added a lot of value generation—three more
general purpose options, and five cards that
contain a particular mechanic I wanted to play
around with: the initiative. The initiative is a
mechanic that causes a player to travel through
the Undercity, which triggers an effect in a
room whenever a player “takes the initiative”,
whenever they start their turn with the
initiative, or whenever they take back
the initiative from an opponent who stole it by
attacking them. It’s like Monarch, but needlessly
complicated for entirely aesthetic purposes.
Anyway, this had some undeniable appeals. In
a slow-paced game, any once-per-turn triggers
naturally gain a bit of extra relevance. Also,
my deck already benefitted from running a small
handful of defensive cards due to its grindy,
life-total-race-winning commander, and these
defensive cards also help with keeping the
initiative. Also, I didn’t have an undercity
token, so I drew one on a full-sized piece of
paper, and brought miniatures to commander games
so that people could represent their positions on
it, and who wouldn’t love that? Well, me, and
that was part of my issue with this version
of the deck. A commander deck can easily be
this pretty compact, self-contained thing,
and here I’d introduced an extra mechanic that
required me to use this full sheet of paper prop,
or else buy a replacement that’s irritatingly
small? It just felt like a pointless extra hassle
to need to deal with, particularly given that my
deck only ran 5 initiative cards and didn’t draw
any of them in some games. The other part of my
issue was that I’d cut a bunch of damaging cards
in order to make the round of changes I’d made,
and while those damaging cards weren’t great,
their absence pulled the deck even further away
from the life-total-pressuring ideal that I’d be
striving for. I had a functional
deck that I didn’t mind playing,
but the itch was still not being scratched.
So, it was time for another change.
One of my favorite cards in the deck was Breena,
the Demagogue. She is a three mana creature with
the text “Whenever a player attacks one of your
opponents, if that opponent has more life than
another of your opponents, that attacking
player draws a card and you put two +1/+1
counters on a creature you control.” It might
not be immediately clear what that means, but
basically drawing her instantly granted the deck
a whole bunch of both value generation and damage
in the form of +1/+1 counters, and also created
a fun sort of political game for my opponents.
In theory she offered opponents card advantage,
but trading a card for two +1/+1 counters on one
of my creatures didn’t usually feel too bad, and
her benefits were much more consistent on my side
of the table. After four or five games of drawing
her and greatly enjoying what she did to the deck,
I decided to rework the deck with her in the
command zone. In theory, this swap made sense
to me. Liesa is damage-focused commander
who operates through the use of a life tax,
and Breena is a damage-focused commander who
operated through the use of +1/+1 counters.
My theory about having a hatebear-oriented 99
along with a commander who pushed a lot of damage?
Still absolutely intact. The other appeal here
was that hatebears are naturally a type of card
better-suited to somewhat higher power games, and
Breena was a more powerful commander than Liesa,
so that was an added bit of congruence. With this
new bird in the zone, I was better equipped to
handle the sorts of higher-power commander
games that Thalia’s blade was itching for.
So, how was that? Well, in a lot of ways I was
correct, and the deck I ended up producing was
undoubtedly a workable one that I could
have some fun playing. It got going fast,
Breena’s +1/+1 counters could turn my hatebears
into terrifying beaters, and the card advantage
options meant it rarely totally ran out of steam.
Even better, with such a potent command zone,
I could afford to run more interaction than ever
before without sacrificing other things. So,
what was the problem? Put simply, the nature of
a Breena command zone is dramatically different
from the nature of a Liesa command zone, and
it’s different in a way that totally destroyed
the feel of the deck that I was going for. On
some level Liesa is an inevitability commander,
an unstoppable life total tax that always
represents a way to grind the game toward
a single-digit-hitpoint slogfest. With her in
the command zone, the 99 could focus on keeping
opponents in check and putting in chip damage,
knowing that every chunk of health my opponents
lost was a spell they couldn’t safely cast later
in the game. By contrast, Breena is very much
a tempo commander, as I laid out in my glass
cannon commanders video last year. Like Liesa,
she helps me deal a ton of damage to opponents,
but the profile of that damage is front-loaded and
reliant on creatures sticking around on board.
If I had a smooth first several turns, I might
be swinging in with a few 7/7s or 8/8s or 9/9s
on turn 5, and if those creatures stuck around
there was a solid chance I’d be winning that game.
Problem was, if some of my creatures got removed,
or if god-forbid there was a board wipe played
that I couldn’t dodge, all of that damage momentum
would slow to a stall. In that case I’d still
have some card advantage from Breena drawing me an
extra 1-2 cards per turn, but it would take some
time for me to re-develop a board that could once
again threaten opponents, and whether I could
pull that off successfully might come down to
a variety of different factors. To be clear,
what I’m describing is a very normal type of
deck. If your deck works like this, that’s fine,
and I did enjoy some things about playing it. It
even makes sense as an aggro deck—this deck came
out of the gate swinging, and routinely knocked
50 points of life off of its opponents within
the first six turns of the game, even in games
it eventually lost control of. The problem
was, I wasn’t just looking for an aggro deck,
I was looking for a sort of inevitability-aggro
experience where opponents would spend time
dealing with the consequences of a painfully low
life total. And, this deck decidedly was not that.
So, how did I solve my aggro problem? How did
I create a deck that scratches this itch of
wanting opponents to spend a lot of time looking
at their life total? Well, step one was going back
to Liesa. Part of me was a little hesitant to
do this for purely power reasons, because the
Breena deck had been sort of bracket 4 curious,
and Liesa is a pretty firmly mid-power sort of
commander. A small part of me wishes she drained
opponents for 3 per spell, but alas, my girl
Liesa just doesn’t quite have that kind of sauce.
However, this fact also gives some opportunities,
the biggest one of which I’ll get to in a bit. To
start with, though, let’s talk about how I fixed
some of the issues from the previous Liesa decks.
A big piece of this was the beatdown suite—an
issue with previous iterations of the deck was
that the 99 didn’t actually do a good job getting
life totals low enough for Liesa to matter. In
the case of the original deck that was a result
of running a bunch of mediocre damage tools such
as Blood Artist effects, and in the initiative
version that was just not really running very many
damage tools in general, unless you count making
target opponent lose 5 life once every 5 turns.
So here, assisted by a more lax budget than I
was using in the past, I picked out a bunch of new
damage options. Ankh of Mishra, Wound Reflection,
Suture Priest, and iconic political aggro
tool Hunted Horror. This card is so much fun,
and if you have an opponent who’s receptive to
the idea of smacking Fredrick over there who’s
playing a gross value pile, it’s effectively
13/13 in stats for 2 mana. In terms of value,
I dialed into the small creature beats realm and
grabbed Enduring Innocence, Assemble the Players,
and Elegy Acolyte. This deck is running
more draw-oriented cards than the original,
and while it’s running less value generation in
total than the initiative version of the deck,
much of the draw here is quite dense
and impactful. Barrowgoyf was a final
inclusion here as just an all-around solid
beatstick with a bunch of value attached.
The biggest area I tweaked this deck, though, was
dead-simple: I cut a lot of hate-bears. This was
kind of painful, because I really like having
hate bears in my deck. It feels good to have a
way to slow opposing gameplans, to build around
the restrictions of those tools so I’m breaking
parity, and to be able to keep a high power
table in check with something like a rule of
law effect. And to be clear, I’m still running
some—some taxes, some enters-tapped effects,
an Aven Mindcensor—but the real gameplan
smashers like Hushbringer and Archon of Emeria
got left behind. One reason for this I alluded to
earlier—these cards feel most appropriate and most
needed in higher bracket games, and Liesa isn’t
a commander that really belongs at those tables.
The other reason for this choice was that stax in
general, and rule-of-law effects in particular,
have this weird clash with Liesa because
they cause opponents to cast fewer spells,
but Liesa wants opponents to be casting more
spells, or at least wants the fact that spells
cost 2 life to feel relevant. It almost felt like
doing her a little dirty as well as undermining
the goal of the deck. Like, think about it:
if I have an opponent at a low-ish life total,
Liesa in play, and also a Phyrexian Censor in
play, is Liesa reducing the number of spells my
opponent wants to play? The answer is who knows!
They’re not running a whole-ass Phyrexian deck,
they can only play one spell a turn anyway! In a
way, this is similar to some lessons I’ve stumbled
into with my other decks. When I’m making a deck
to celebrate Astral Slide based value engines,
I don’t want to run more generic sources of
draw that might step on the toes of what I’m
celebrating. When I’m making a deck to bask
in the glory of having 20 lands in play,
I don’t want to run a bunch of high-quality
finishers that will end the game as soon as
I’m at 12 or 13. The same goes here—this is a
deck intended to celebrate Liesa in specific
and group-slug-aggro in general, and though a bit
of stax can be nice to manage the pace of a game,
it’s a powerful tool whose ability to warp
the playstyle of a deck needs to be respected.
Still, I find it hard to fault my past impulses
too much. Aggro remains arguably the hardest
archetype to build, particularly a sort of grindy,
resilient aggro that poses a continuing threat to
any greedy opponents. For that reason, this deck
probably isn’t going to ever enter the same sort
of “finished” state that I’m willing to mentally
categorize some of my other decks as being in.
However, after focusing in harder on what makes
this deck satisfying, the current version feels
much better than either previous iteration of
Liesa. The deck’s average mana value has gone
up over time, and yet the current version feels
like it’s packing more quality 2-mana plays than
previous ones. The reason why this is becomes
clear when I filter each deck by mana value in
Archidekt and then look at what’s actually there:
whereas the older versions had a lot of kinda
filler 2 mana cards like Blood Artist effects
and catchup ramp, the current version’s 2 drops
are almost entirely value engines and actually
decent beatdown tools. Another way I honed my
intentions here was being willing to accept a
firmly bracket 3 status and adapt my playstyle
to be more appropriate to that. The deck still
punches above its weight class against decks
that lean in a combo or storm sort of direction,
but it’s no longer the lumbering pile of stax
that it was before, and that lets it feel much
more appropriate in a wider range of contexts.
So broadly, the current version of this deck feels
like a success in figuring out what I wanted from
it above all else, and the funny thing is, I think
the year with Breena in the command zone was a
really important part of that. There are a lot of
cards out there with a powerful, iconic playstyle,
and there’s a reason people gravitate toward
them. They feel good to draw, and good to play,
and if you could put one in the command zone,
why wouldn’t you? If that specific thing is
something you want every single game rather than
just occasionally, that might absolutely be the
right call. Even if it’s not meant to be long
term, as it wasn’t in this case, playing with
more extreme command zone choices can be a great
exercise in figuring out what you do or don’t
enjoy about your deck, and it’s absolutely worth
a try if you have a deck you’re not happy with!
Thanks for watching! You can catch me this
weekend at LDXP Tacoma, where I’ll be along with
my podcast cohosts 3/3 Elk and The Trinket Mage.
I’ll be there with my Dragonshield-sleeved decks,
and if you want to be enjoying the same excellent
durability and wide range of design options,
you can follow my affiliate link down in the
description and score yourself some with a
little discount. If you want to support what I do
here another way, you can become a YouTube member
or join my Patreon, and you’ll receive access
to a back catalogue of bonus videos along with
a new one I’m putting out around the same time as
this video drops. That one will feature me doing
a deep dive into the first two Liesa lists, and
a preview for that video will start RIGHT NOW!